while individuals going through life can
know ahead of time the experience that
they're probably going to encounter they
can't know exactly what going through
that experience is going to be like
until they go through it however they
can get good guidance and good
principles for dealing with them from
those who have successfully gone through
them before that is why mentoring is so
important to navigate this life cycle
well it's important to know where you
are in that life cycle where the people
you who matter to you most are in in
their life cycles and then seek out good
principles for dealing with the most
important things that will be coming at
you and them I suggest that you look and
see where you are and what's likely to
come over the next 10 years which you
probably can pretty well vision visualiz
by seeing how the typical life cycle
goes and also modifying the picture for
your own
circumstances you can gain good
principles from dealing with most of the
things that are going to come at you
because they happen to many people
before in many lifetimes before and good
principles are available from many wise
people who have successfully gone
through these things